now on Friday of course the chancellor
announced new legislation to require
unions to put pay offers to staff before
calling strikes well quite also wants
so-called minimum service levels to stop
strikes shutting down transport networks
as well now unions as you might expect
uh condemned the move as more strikes
are announced on the rail network with a
threat of action across the economy and
public services as well now the UK's
biggest Union is Unison with 1.3 million
members that work in public services and
I'm delighted to say the general
secretary Christina mcaney is with us
now thank you very much for being uh
with us this morning well it wasn't a
mini Budget on Friday was it it was a
mega budget the biggest tax cuts for
half a century
um what impact do you think that might
have on public services well as ever
they'll be the ones that are expected to
pay for this
um I mean the irony is during austerity
years when we had Cameron and um uh
George Osborne selling this everyone was
in it together and uh you know we had to
cut back and public sector website to
take a pay for these and now it's spent
and again I'm pretty certain it'll be
public sector workers and public
services that will actually end up
paying for this because they'll they've
already announced they want big reforms
they want to um they're telling us to
exercise peer restraint and it seems
under the this government public
services are just no and not a priority
at all now Unison is balloting it's a
NHS workers over strike action so we
could see you know nurses going on
strike midwives going on strike
you know a lot of our viewers might be a
bit worried about what that means right
you know because you can't choose the
timing of when to have a straight you
can't use when to have a baby when I
can't delay it till after strike action
isn't patient safety going to be a bit
at risk here well patient safety is
always Paramount we have struck we're
having strikes before we had the strike
in 2014 in England England and Wales and
uh we will always put in minimum to that
safe Staffing levels uh the interesting
thing is when uh less trusted was going
to bring in minimum Staffing levels
we've been calling for that for years in
the NHS because we don't have it and
what our members uh and what the members
are telling me you know so paramedics or
nurses they're cleaners in hospitals are
seeing things like the service is so
badly run down it's on its knees there's
not enough staff and actually taking
strike action they don't think will make
it any worse but what it might help do
is one get them more money when they're
totally struggling but to actually draw
attention to the fact that the
government has no problem plan or
strategy for dealing with some of their
major and essential Public Services I
guess what I don't understand is if
Staffing is so stretched in the NHS
under so much pressure then surely
strike action is going to make things
worse how could it not well
straight action has to be effective and
by that it must have an impact in any
sector but certainly where it's about
people's life and safety there will
always be a life in line policy we will
always agree with local employers
certain levels of cover but it does mean
other things won't get done it will have
an impact without a doubt what kind of
impact could it have well sometimes they
might have to cancel operations
um
certain clinics won't open but essential
life-saving things you know in a e
departments as you see in maternity
departments will still continue because
everybody knows you can't choose when
you're going to have a baby so you won't
get midways walking off a ward when
there's women in labor that just won't
happen but we could have more delayed
operations canceled operations yes yes
that could happen understood
um so you're also you are launching
legal action I think I might say against
the government's trying to stop the use
of agency workers to cover uh struggling
nurses is that correct yeah so just
explain so the government's brought in
late or started legislation to bring in
to allow employers to bring in agency
workers when basically a straight
breaker so in we have legislation
currently in this country and indeed
most of Europe which says you can't do
that and the government in this wisdom
on the lack of has decided they're going
to change that now not only are we
concerned about it the organizations
that represent agency workers are
concerned about her isn't that about
ensuring patient safety well whatever
you do have enough people to look after
people in hospitals if it's necessary
there's a hundred and forty thousand
vacancies in the NHS at the moment that
aren't the agency workers out there to
come and do it and if there are people
who have chosen to you know give their
services through an agency it's because
they get paid so much more more than you
would if they're employed by the NHS and
that's a problem for the country as a
whole and you do I mean this thing about
removing the cap and bankers bonuses
because they're losing good people where
is the evidence for that or is this just
dinner party talk where the friends say
oh Dreadful I'm going to have to go to
Hong Kong to get more money I can
actually provide hard evidence of 140
000 vacancies in the NHS 160 000
vacancies in the Care Service why don't
the government do something about that
we're seeing uh strikes um being called
or ballasted on across so many
Industries with inflation high and
people feeling their wages aren't
keeping up do you think we're getting
close to a general strike
well
we're certainly getting close to a
well-coordinated strike across different
sectors now in the past is that a
general strike no there's a legal
definition of a general strike as far as
I'm aware which is it's predominantly a
political act and there's very strong
tough legislation in this country that
makes that virtually impossible so it's
not impossible but it's not you know we
probably wouldn't call it a general
strike but what you would call it is a
strike across a whole range of sectors
at the same time which is not the same
as a general straight and it sounds a
lot of people might say look it's a
coordinator strike or across different
sectors and unions it is kind of a
general strike well if I was to see
we're calling a general street my
Union's funds would be sequestered any
of the members who took part in what's
called a political strike would lose any
protection from dismissal they would
just be sacked so if you don't call it a
general strike then well it's not a bit
not calling it what we're doing isn't
going through legal process to bring our
members out safely and legally and give
them the protection we have the toughest
industrial relations legislation in this
country you have to jump through about
10 12 herbs just to be able to bring
people out on legal strikes and that's
why this sort of demonizing of of
workers who are already on strike is so
unfair because this is oh they're taking
part in legal disputes and legal strikes
and that take part in unlawful strikes
would you like to see a tougher line
from labor on this
um
you know to be quite honest I don't
think it makes a difference whether
laborer our own picket lines are not
labor is there
to I think hopefully work with us and I
think if there was a labor government in
place I would hope that we wouldn't be
just about to bow at 400 000 NHS workers
by the end of this year and we talked
that we've talked to us I wrote to Liz
twist let's trust the day she got
elected and congratulated her and said
we'd be happy to work with her but they
obviously see unions as part of the
problem and actually strikes are a
symptom of problems they're not the
cause of the problems and we're willing
to work with them pretty certain Francis
O'Grady from the General Secretary of
the TUC would be well into work with her
but we're getting nothing back from this
government other than you getting much
back from labor yeah yeah and we want
Western more and you know new policies
that are coming forward we don't get
everything we want because you know they
want to govern the country for everyone
not just for trade unions and therefore
we wouldn't get everything that we want
but we can certainly try and influence
them and work with them to get to get
changes in that actually benefit working
people thanks very much for being on the
program today good to talk to you thank
you